obviously Baywatch was popular otherwise
it wouldn't have run for more than 200
episodes over more than a decade
launched the careers of multiple people
and inspired a movie of the same name
but what is a little surprising is how
staggeringly popular the show was at the
peak of its run by the mid 90s each
episode was viewed by 1.1 billion people
on average across more than 142
countries and translated into 15
languages that means roughly one in five
people worldwide tuned into Baywatch
broken down into male and female viewers
one might assume that the swimsuit
clad's audience was overwhelmingly male
but according to the LA Times about
two-thirds of Baywatch viewers were
women the reason according to co-creator
Greg bonan is that its female characters
were positive role models who were
athletic professional intelligent and
able to make any rescue a man can make
wrong
nothing at vacation wouldn't be fixed